que puede esperarse de una empresa como
Twitter que sea controlada por una sola
persona más ha hecho en repetidas
ocasiones que él va a defender la
libertad de expresión
si yo creo que vamos a ver dos cosas muy
rápidamente el primero vamos a ver una
depuración grandísima de lo que son los
usuarios falsos las cuentas Bots y demás
él lo ha expresado durante mucho tiempo
alrededor del tema y lo otro seguramente
vamos a empezar a ver un cambio en el
modelo de negocio pero lo más importante
es un tweet que puso precisamente él
esta mañana en el que está diciendo lo
que queremos crear es una plaza pública
donde todo el mundo pueda intercambiar
ideas de manera educada y no
permitiremos que esto se vuelva
básicamente un infierno donde la gente
pueda decir lo que quiera sin ninguna
consecuencia también hay dudas como
sigue adelantaba sobre el modelo de
negocio y finalmente qué va a pasar será
una empresa que vivirá de la publicidad
o de la suscripciones
seguramente veremos suscripciones y
veremos otros otros ingresos que se
pueden venir usted claramente estamos
viendo un modelo más parecido a lo que
hace WeChat en China que a lo que hace
Facebook en Estados Unidos la publicidad
hoy en día para Twitter representa como
el 85% de sus ingresos y yo creería que
de aquí a dos años vamos a ver un cambio
importante en ese rubro para tratar de
volver a crecer y volver la compañía
mucho más rentable una preocupación que
hay entre los empleados son los posibles
recortes de personal por el vuelco
estratégico que él quiere darle a esa
empresa que sabemos al respecto
ayer estuvo él precisamente las oficinas
hablando con los empleados en Nueva York
y digamos dejó Claro que no van a
despedir al 75% de los de los empleados
como se había rumorado pero es Claro que
debe haber una estrategia en la que va a
haber algún tipo de cambio entonces
seguramente veremos algunos despidos al
interior de la compañía